il est bon il est 20h bonsoir à tous
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
samedi
nous reviendrons ce soir sur la mort
d'alain bashung le chanteur était malade
depuis plusieurs mois il est décédé à
l'âge de 61 ans à l'hôpital saint-joseph
à paris aujourd'hui dans l'actualité
également un accident de canyoning qui a
coûté la vie à trois sapeurs pompiers
dans l'un il avait pourtant l'habitude
de ce type d' escalade nous tenterons de
comprendre ce qu'il s'est passé dans un
instant tension et confusion ce soir à
madagascar où l'opposition affirment
avoir pris le contrôle du siège du
gouvernement
le maire de la capitale enjolras où elle
est réapparue au côté des militaires
cette fois notre envoyée spéciale
dominique derda et sur place à la veille
du choc psg marseille notre enquête ce
soir vous verrez comment certains
supporters parisiens pourtant jugé
indésirable il ya seulement quelques
mois seront au stade demain soir les
raisons et les explications à suivre ce
soir les résultats de sports et jean
baptiste grange qui remporte la coupe du
monde de ski ans alors le quinze de
france lui se prépare à affronter
l'angleterre
un combat qui s'annonce engagée nous
irons à l'ombre et puis nous
retrouverons à la fin de ce journal
bénabar il est en concert au zénith de
paris ce soir il nous apportera son
témoignage après l'annonce donc du décès
d'alain bashung aujourd'hui bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous et comment ce
journal par cette information qui nous
est parvenu il ya une demi-heure le
chanteur alain bashung est mort à l'âge
de 61 ans aujourd'hui à l'hôpital
saint-joseph de paris à la machine qui
était atteint d'un cancer du poumon
venait d'interrompre sa tournée
on se souvient bien sûr de son
apparition il ya seulement quinze jours
lors des victoires de la musique était
apparu extrêmement fatiguée et surprise
extrêmement ému par l'hommage qui lui
avait été rendu c'était le 28 février
je voudrais vous remercier parce que
vous m'avez beaucoup aidé vous m'avez
envoyé tellement d'amour qui se sont
lancés avec moi dans une tournée qui
pouvait s'arrêter n'importe quand et
puis ils ont ils ont continué quand même
ils m'ont fait confiance et nous allons
revenir sur cette information dans ce
journal nous reviendrons sur sa carrière
et puis tout à l'heure avec nous le
chanteur bénabar qu'est réagir à cette
information dans l'actualité également
aujourd'hui cet accident de canyoning
dans l'ain accident qui a coûté la vie
hier soir à trois sapeurs pompiers tout
cela s'est déroulé dans un site très
sauvage est connu pour sa dangerosité
on va retrouver notre envoyé spécial
dans un instant même en cela les fait
que s'est il passé
jean françois feer et fifi la cascade de
foot se niche au coeur du massif du
budget le site magnifique et très prisée
des amateurs de canyoning ce sport
d'escaladé qui consiste à descendre les
chutes dans rappelle ici hier après-midi
deux pompiers de 30 et 40 ans originaire
de bourg-en-bresse décide de venir
s'entraîner vers 19 heures les familles
s'inquiètent de ne pas les voir rentrer
elles préviennent les secours qui
interviennent à la tombée de la nuit et
découvre les deux hommes noyé sous la
cascade
mais le drame ne s'arrête pas là
malheureusement lors de cette opération
un des secours et ceux à glisser et a
été projeté dans l'eau et a sauté une
cascade
au total trois morts trois pompiers qui
n'ont pu être sortis des eaux que ce
midi par hélicoptère
les secours ne parvenait à se rendre à
pied sur les lieux d'autant que sur les
hauteurs la neige fond le début de la
cascade est très important en ce moment
le maire de la commune de serres dont
avait déjà alerté du danger aujourd'hui
elle crie sa colère
il faut qu'on ait une réflexion de fond
sur la réglementation pour savoir
comment comment faire pour cadrer les
activités de ce type sur des rivières à
débit torrentielle comme la foule à une
trentaine de kilomètres au centre des
pompiers d'ambérieu-en-bugey les
familles se sont réunis cet après midi
dans la petite salle interdites aux
caméras
pas de corps mais des objets chers aux
disparus des photos leurs casques de
pompiers des collègues se sont également
recueillis comme des frères unis dans la
douleur
vous comprenez bien très très ému de
cette situation même s'ils savent les
uns les autres
cela fait partie du risque delà des
risques de leur engagement
l' enquête devra dire avec exactitude ce
qui s'est passé pour les proches des
victimes et les pompiers
c'est une longue période de deuil qui
commence les obsèques maintenant
meurthe-et-moselle d'ophélie bretnacher
le corps de la jeune étudiante française
avait été retrouvé le 12 février dernier
sur les bords du danube à budapest
je vous rappelle qu'une autopsie cette
semaine avait une nouvelle fois conclu à
un décès par noyade
les actions maintenant madagascar où les
événements se sont donc précipités ces
dernières heures doit-on parler de coup
d'état en tout cas le principal opposant
au régime qui avait disparu depuis le 5
mars le maire de la capitale anglaise où
elle est réapparue aujourd'hui et la
firme désormais avoir pris le contrôle
du siège du gouvernement le pouvoir de
la présidence semble ne plus tenir qu'à
un fil sur place nous envoyés spéciaux
dominique derda freda écran qu'est
sylvain par allah
cette fois il en est persuadé le pouvoir
est à portée de main ses partisans aussi
qui l'acclament sur son passage
ces derniers jours en rade où elle se
cachait il craignait pour cesse depuis
qu'une partie de l'armée de la
gendarmerie de la police et rallier à
lui le maire de la capitale se sent
invulnérable devant 10000 au moins de
ses fidèles une nouvelle fois ils
réclament le départ du président
malgache et lui donne quatre heures
dit-il pour abandonner ses fonctions
c'est lui désormais qui veut dicter sa
loi
notre espoir c'est qu'il démissionne
démissionne pour goûter les agressions
de pouvoir par la force
la question qu'on ne pouvoir par la mort
l'empathie dion
quelques heures plus tôt à la surprise
générale escorté lui aussi par des
membres des forces de l'ordre
le premier ministre nommé par
l'opposition a investi le bureau du
premier ministre officiel le bâtiment
était vite samedi matin personne pour en
interdire l'accès à tananarive à
l'évidence le pouvoir chancelle
retranché au palais marc ravalomanane
que nous voyons ici sur des images
d'archivés et hésiterait selon ses
proches sur la conduite à tenir
lui qui par deux fois a remporté les
suffrages des électeurs veut bien
reconnaître des erreurs dans la gestion
du pays mais il ne démissionnera pas
lui aussi a ses supporters prêts à
mourir dit-il pour le protéger nous
sommes ici pour défendre notre président
république
nous sommes ici pour défendre notre
choix avant de te dire aux français à
madagascar
nous ne voulons que vivre en paix nous
voulons uniquement des gens qu'ils
soient élus du peuple
c'est seulement et qui peuvent diriger
ce pays
on ne peut pas prendre le pouvoir de
force quelle que soit la raison
tout au long de l'après midi ils ont
érigé des barrages sur la route de
yabulu de part et d'autre on craint des
débordements
ce soir plus que jamais madagascar est
dans l'impasse entre un président élu
qui refuse de céder à la pression de la
rue un opposant qui se sent porté par la
foule
la marge de manoeuvre était 3 d'autant
que depuis plusieurs jours il n'y a plus
aucune négociation entre les deux camps
on a appris cet après midi que les
quatre humanitaires de médecins sans
frontières qui avaient été kidnappés au
darfour mercredi ont été libérés ils
sont donc sains et saufs informations
cette fois confirmée par les autorités
soudanaises
que faut-il penser de ce message la
chaîne de télévision al jazira a diffusé
aujourd'hui un enregistrement attribué à
oussama ben laden il y accuse certains
pays arabes de complicité avec israël et
ses alliés lors de la récente offensive
dans la bande de gaza le dernier message
authentifié du chef d'al qaïda remontait
au 14 janvier dernier on revient en
france avec la fin du conflit en
martinique après 38 jours de grève un
accord a été signé cet après midi entre
les représentants de l'état les
organisations patronales le collectif du
5 février qui était je vous le rappelle
à l'origine du mouvement social contre
la vie chère social toujours avec cette
question maintenant peut-on payer ses
salariés en deux fois à reims le patron
d'une entreprise a mis en place ce
système de paiement des salaires ont
raison de la crise qu'ils traversent ces
salariés ont décidé de se mettre en
grève plus de ben aziza
ce bulletin de paye a déclenché une
grève pour les 18 salariés de
l'entreprise iss du site de saint
léonard près de reims depuis lundi
dernier
en cause le paiement étalé la direction
a décidé de verser les sommes en deux
fois sur un salaire mensuelle habituelle
de 1200 euros par exemple ses salariés
au dernier jour du mois constate un
manque à gagner de 120 euros pour
toucher cette somme qui leur est dû il
leur faut attendre le 11 du mois suivant
en fait 90 % du salaire à la fin du mois
puis les 10% restants onze jours plus
tard on n'est pas d'accord
franchement les mecs pour les crédits
les gens qui ont des crédits ne peuvent
pas faire face aux prêts d'ici là les
prélèvements qui arrive de vie chez les
rouges
il ya des gens qui chantent souvent la
misère avec ça une décision unilatérale
de la direction communiqué par une
simple note d'intention salariés de
cette entreprise de nettoyage se fait
sur le travail nous suivent sur le sur
le coup elle me dit bien évidemment cet
aigle égale les salaires peuvent être
payants deux fois à la demande du
salarié mais pas sur le décision
unilatérale de l'employeur
on est prêt à aller devant les tribunaux
et on est prêts bien évidemment le cas
échéant à faire dérailler le restant de
la france je rappelle quand même mais
500 salariés dans l'entreprise un
conflit qui pourrait donc devenir
contagieux pour l'ensemble du groupe le
paiement des salaires en deux fois ne
pourra être légale qu'après la signature
d'un accord entre direction et salariés
l'attaqué de mardi dans un lycée à
gagner a remis au coeur de l'actualité
la question des bandes violentes le
président république a demandé à la
ministre de l'intérieur de lui présenter
un plan d'action d'ici la fin du mois
illustration ce soir de ces conflits
entre jeunes de différents quartiers
nous sommes rendus à gonesse dans le val
d'oise c'est le grand format de ce soir
arnaud compte samuel et mathieu ni
wendel au ski dans la cité de la
fauconnière tout le monde connaît son
histoire
à 20 ans je lui dis qu'elle est
paraplégique il vit en fauteuil roulant
depuis trois ans là cela que j'étais
allongée pour les pompes et on trouve au
foot allongé dans l'herbe
depuis ce soir d'octobre 2006 où il se
retrouve au coeur d'une bataille rangée
entre deux bandes de gonesse des coups
de feu éclatent
judicaël reçoit une balle dans le dos
une balle perdue dit il moi j'étais venu
prendre mon bus ici là j'ai trouvé les
pieds de mon quartier j'ai serré la main
normale et voilages attendait le bus et
voilà ça s'embrouille et j'ai couru dans
ce sens là et j'ai pris la balle j'étais
allongé par terre là l'auteur du coup de
feu jugé cette semaine a été condamné à
quatre ans de prison jeudi qu'elle
qualifie cette peine de normal mais il
nous confie n'avoir jamais eu de haine
envers son agresseur
s'il garde la haine mois et que mon
frère et mon petit frère qui est qu'à
dix ans ils voient que j'ai la haine
comme ça que je veux manger que je peux
pas parce que je suis en fauteuil il va
grandir avec ça ça va jamais changer on
va dire mon grand frère il est comme ça
regardez ce qu'ils ont fait à mon grand
frère
quand il l'aura l'ajout de l'âge que
j'ai maintenant une barge venir ça va
empirer toujours en cours on a fait
longtemps que ça dure et ils savent même
pas pourquoi ils se battent
des fois il se bat qui les posent des
questions ils savent même pas à gonesse
26 mille habitants de quartiers se font
face la fauconnière et ses barres
d'immeubles les marronniers et ses
petits pavillons de citer séparés par
cette voie de chemin de fer et pour se
rendre à pied d'un quartier à l'autre
ce petit pont que les jeunes habitants
de gonesse appelle le pont des
embrouilles une frontière invisible
et ces lieux de rendez-vous pakaya
steven n'a que 14 ans il n'en est pas à
sa première bagarre des affrontements
parfois violents
vous vous battez avec wade parle des
points cailloux ou qe2 verse les
pensions
impossible
il n'ya souvent pas de réponse et les
rivalités s'entretiennent depuis
quelques années face à cet engrenage de
la violence
les parents sont impuissants c'est un
peu c'est 38 dollar se tenait une image
d'être costauds parce qu'on a un couteau
parce qu'on a un flingue
alors que bon bah se battent à coups
devant rentrer avec un coquard on met
des mots clairs et pis voilà ça se voit
plus mais ils ont des flingues comme
vous dites moi j'entends il est arrivé
dans la cité saint françois ont entendu
des coups de feu
ouais effectivement suite pour ne pas
que son histoire se répète
judicaël souhaite rapprocher par la
chanson les adolescents des deux
quartiers où sont sur son bras il a
gravé le mou rescapés rescapé d'une
guerre de bandes en mettant ses pas
20h10 ce samedi le sommaire à suivre de
votre journal à la veille du choc psg om
notre enquête sur certains supporters
parisiens jugés indésirables qui seront
pourtant demain en tribune jean baptiste
grange remporté la coupe du monde de ski
en slalom et puis le rugby le quinze de
france et en angleterre et s'attend à un
défi physique et puis nous allons
revenir dans un instant sur la mort du
chanteur alain bashung reportages et
puis témoignages bénabar est avec nous
il chantera ce soir au zénith de paris
mais avant cela ce nouveau suicide en
prison à moulins dans l'allier un détenu
âgé de 17 ans s'est donné la mort la
nuit dernière le jeune homme avait déjà
connu la détention à plusieurs reprises
l'administration pénitentiaire n'a
apporté aucune autre information sur ce
décès demain paris saint-germain recevra
l'olympique de marseille au parc des
princes une nouvelle fois un important
dispositif de sécurité sera mis en place
nous avons voulu savoir si les mesures
visant à éloigner certains hooligans
étaient toujours efficace et bien
apparemment non certains de ses
supporters pourtant jugés indésirables
seront bel et bien dans le stade demain
pourquoi celle en quête de ce journal
fonctionne au zoo vincent barras
obliger les suporters indésirable à
pointer au commissariat
au moment des matches c'est le principe
de l'interdiction de stade préventive
depuis la mort d'un supporteur du psg en
novembre 2006 la mesure était présenté
comme le remède miracle pour éloigner
les supporteurs violents
pourtant depuis trois mois la justice
annule les unes après les autres ces
interdictions
pourquoi parce qu'elles ne sont pas
suffisamment argumenté explique le
tribunal de versailles qui précise le
préfet se borne à produire un document
d'information tiré d'un site internet
pour tout élément de preuve ce document
le voici un simple article sur les
supporteurs du psg
tiré de l'encyclopédie wikipedia des
dossiers mal ficelés qui ont abouti au
versement de dommages et intérêts pour
les supporteurs concernés le préfet à
chaque ars été annulés et condamné en
général à 500 euros ou à 1000 euros
selon les cas et nous sommes aujourd'hui
à plusieurs milliers d'euros de
condamnation du préfet officiellement
pas de commentaires de la part de la
préfecture
mais en haut lieu on explique assumer
cette stratégie résultats à l'appui le
parc des princes n'a connu que peu
d'incidents depuis deux ans l'idée étant
d'éloigner du stade le plus longtemps
possible les indésirables
c'est ce qui est arrivé à ceux
supporteurs réputés violents obligé de
pointer au commissariat jusqu'à quatre
soirs par semaine on m'a bousillé les
huitièmes où est une gifle rien faire
qu'est ce qui vous a fait arrêter si
vous a fait plier sous cette pression
cette pression s'est déjà je pense à ma
famille
je me retrouve en cabale juste arbres
boulot découragé il n'a selon lui jamais
remis les pieds au stade mais d'autres
ont fait valoir leurs droits 15 août
était blanchi 35 serait en passe de
l'être
des supporteurs dont la préfecture
maintient qu'il doive être violent
demain ils pourront pourtant assisté à
la fiche psg om en toute légalité
internet fête ses 20 ans déjà plus rien
n'échappe désormais à la toile un outil
pratique mais également extrêmement un
discret sur le côté dr jekyll et mr hyde
du réseau ainsi la divulgation de
certaines informations privées parce que
peuvent avoir des conséquences
insoupçonnées lionel feierstein cette
mauvaise blague va sans doute lui coûter
sa place
fin février ce surveillant d'un lycée à
nîmes
mais sur internet ce sketch il y joue le
rôle d'un riverains exaspérés par le
bruit de la feria pas de chance quelques
jours plus tard son directeur tombe sur
la vidéo ça lui a fait peur alors il m'a
pris certainement pour un brin pour un
terroriste et chinon qui m'a comparé
donc à ce jeune homme en belgique là qui
assassine et des nourrissons
sous prétexte que ce jeune homme aurait
aussi fait des vidéos sur internet je
trouve que l'amalgamé un peu rapide quoi
la liberté d'expression le droit à la
vie privée sont ils menacés sur internet
certains sites communautaires peuvent
vous piéger sans le vouloir
aux etats unis l'an dernier un stagiaire
demande par mail à son patron un congé
exceptionnel pour un problème de famille
à cordes etc
mais peu de temps après un autre
collègue retrouve cette photo sur
facebook
l'homme était en fait à une soirée
halloween il a été licencié en france
est un salarié de michelin qui a été
mise à la porte
il avait évoqué sur un forum son travail
de bagnard on discute avec les pollens
mais aussi un petit qu'un petit
commentaire et puis on dit 100 ans ou
même je n'ai mis un smiley à la fin pour
nous ce qu'on pensait que quelqu'un nous
a balancé
selon michelin ses employés ont tous un
devoir de loyauté même sur internet
alors attention à ce que vous laissez
sur la toile une mauvaise réputation
virtuelle peut aussi vous coûter très
cher le sport maintenant avec le sac de
jean baptiste grange en coupe du monde
de ski paris-nice en vélo et manchester
united corrigé à domicile par liverpool
c'est du football et c'est le
championnat d'angleterre manuel tissier
un petit globe de cristal pour jean
baptiste grange un grand pas pour le ski
français
le skieur de valloire décroche à 24 ans
la première victoire tricolore depuis
sept ans dans un classement général le
dossard rouge de leader de la coupe du
monde depuis le début de la saison est
bien le meilleur slalomeur de l'hiver
grange avait échoué d'un cheveu l'an
dernier blessée par ses échecs aux
mondiaux de val d'isère en février sa
troisième place ce matin dans l'ultime
épreuve de la saison suffit à son
bonheur elle a tourné dans le bon sens
ça faisait beaucoup de fois quand même
que sa tournée dans le mauvais le
calvaire d'un maillot jaune l'espagnol
alberto contador s'effondre dans les
derniers kilomètres de la septième étape
de paris-nice le favori de l'épreuve a
tout simplement oublié de manger entre
manosque et fayence une crise
d'hypoglycémie qui relègue contador à
une minute 52 son compatriote sanchez
vainqueur de l'étape et premier du
classement général le français sylvain
chavanel est deuxième avant l'arrivée
demain à nice liverpool relance le
championnat d'angleterre
les coéquipiers de steven gerrard ont
infligé une humiliante défaite à
manchester united 4 buts à 1 pour
liverpool qui revient à quatre points de
son rival du nord de l'angleterre
manchester n'avait plus perdu depuis 16
matches
le rugby les résultats du tournoi des
six nations aujourd'hui deux matches
affichent le pays de galles d'avoir
s'est imposé en italie 20 à 15 et puis
ce soir l'irlande a battu l'ecosse 22 à
15 l'irlande qui est toujours en course
pour remporter le grand chelem cette
année
demain le quinze de france se reposer au
quinze de la rose et l'affrontement
s'annonce très physique selon les
spécialistes à twickenham reportage
christophe duchiron et frédéric bazire
si les matchs de rugby entre la france
et l'angleterre se jouer cartes sur
table
alors il se jouerait avec du pic et sans
coeur rapport à la rivalité sportive
qu'entretiennent le quinze du coq et
celui de la rose ce matin les bleus ont
pris le train puis l'autobus avant de
s'installer non loin du stade à
twickenham là ils se savent attendus au
coin du bois par une bande de types aux
intentions pas très pacifique
le genre présentant mauvais souvenir
certes dans un match franco anglais il
ya toujours un côté farce mais quand
même historiquement nous parlons c'est
toujours le match référence enfin
personnellement pour pour le tournoi de
jeu contre les anglais en plus ce truc
nomme quelque chose me dit que dimanche
après midi à l'heure du thé l'ambiance
ne sera pas les échanges de courtoisie
vu qu'on ne part pas au combat comme on
va au champignon les entraîneurs
français ont préparé une équipe de
combattants
le muscle comptera autant que les
neurones afin d'endormir l'orgueil des
anglais qui restent dans le tournoi sur
deux défaites consécutives
c'est vraiment une capacité de combat
important dix ans puis sauvagement ce
doit être décuplée par un peu toute
l'histoire qui a que quelques civils qui
est dans une période difficile métier
aussi dans une période de construction
les anglais c'est l'équipe qui sont très
costauds de battre et d'aspac très lourd
avec l'entraîneur martin johnson qui est
un très réputé pour le jeu là bas donc
voilà le combat va être primordiale le
dimanche en fin d'après-midi dans ce
très beau jardin anglais cas le stade de
twickenham
les bleus ont fignolé leurs affaires le
gros oeuvre c'est pour dimanche et matt
chassieu bien sûr sur france 2 demain à
16h en direct nous revenons maintenant
sur cette information que nous vous
donnions en début de journal le chanteur
alain bashung est décédé aujourd'hui à
l'âge de 61 ans et souffrait d'un cancer
depuis plusieurs mois revenons sur sa
carrière son talent un rockeur
charismatique qui était devenu
extrêmement populaire
olivier les ninjas il a tenu à être là
depuis des mois il se bat contre la
maladie
quelques jours plus tôt il a annulé
quelques concerts trop fatigué
mais le jour de victoire monsieur alain
bashung est là
que dire que dire que dire merci
c'est magnifique ça brille c'est lourd
est-ce que ça réchauffe le coeur oui ça
réchauffe le coeur
j'ai toujours je ne parle
album artiste spectacle de l'année
jours
j'ai coupé
jusqu'au jour jeu
trois récompenses pour un album sorti
douze mois qui to mars 2008 alain
bashung nous accueillent sur le tournage
d'un clip il est déjà affaibli par le
traitement qui suit mais il ne laisse
rien paraître
fidèle à lui même une élégance infinie
lui l'amour éternel d'une certaine gaby
quel
tu devrais passer
1980 alain vachon touche enfin au but 1
1 million de disques vendus
quinze ans après ses débuts en pleine
période cloclo alain vachon apparaît sa
maison de disques rêve de faire de lui
un chanteur romantique qui jouent le jeu
reprend belles belles belles nourrit de
buddy holly elvis presley
jacques brel il enregistre en 1966 à 19
ans ses premiers 45 tours
vassal
doucement
tu attends plus dense de jack l'homme
qui pouvait imaginer que ce jeune
premier déjà contestataires allait
devenir la force tranquille du rock qui
pendant 40 ans va promener sa solitude
son amour des mots histoire d'eau et ses
déchirures
pour lui monter sur scène c'est comme
aimer la mer et puis avoir envie de la
première occasion de prendre un bateau
de plongée dedans
en espérant que fonctionne un ancien
enfant de choeur gérer c'est un adulte
pétris de doute c'est au dessus
peu d'espoir j'ai besoin de sacré ça
c'est sûr c'est à dire que on me dirait
que plus rien n'est sacré ça me poserais
de sacrés problèmes de repères sinon je
me fabriquer eux mêmes des choses que je
sacralise ray
opposés
un personnage de roman de cinéma il joue
dans une quinzaine de films il jouait
son propre rôle
hamadé en voilà moi je arnaud indiqué
temps discret alain bashung a traversé
la vie dans le plus joli des vertiges
je ne peux y donnera la place
m
voilà un vertige de l'amour nous
retrouvons tout de suite chante le
chanteur bénabar qui est au zénith de
paris ce soir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous tout d'abord une
première réaction qu'est ce que
représentait pour vous à la machine
comme pour beaucoup de monde
un immense artiste quelqu'un de
différent des autres
pour moi c'était un modèle vraiment un
immense personnage très accessible
incroyablement humble et et et à la
carrière et au répertoire extrêmement
riche je suis évidemment comme tout le
monde super bouleversé par vous avez eu
l'occasion à plusieurs reprises de le
rencontrer oui j'ai eu la chance et je
le mesure ce soir d'ailleurs le
privilège de l'avoir rencontré quelques
fois à différentes occasions
ce que j'en ai vu on n'était pas intime
et j'ai eu l'occasion de le fréquenter
un petit peu c'était un homme
extrêmement extrêmement humble
extrêmement gentil gentil à croire que
il savait pas qu'il était alain bashung
quoi en fait on regardait tous nos
comptes dès qu'on le croise est élu au
contraire était très très gentil donc
certes c'est un homme qui a donné qui a
réussi à donner finalement une couleur
assez poétique à son rock oui c'est
quelqu'un qui faisait après quand on
parle de d'alain bashung on parle même
plus de rock ou de cesser vraiment il a
inventé un truc à lui tout seul quoi ces
axes et il a fait quelque chose de très
exigeant musicalement artistiquement
même temps très ouvert très populaire
c'est
je pense alors c'est toujours à la fois
c'est jamais le bon moment dire ça mais
c'est je pense que c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui à cames qui a marqué son
temps à points en tout cas moi je fait
ce qui en a qui n'ont pas fini d'essayer
de copier ses chansons quoi il avait un
charisme c'est vrai étonnant et puis
c'est un acteur également oui oui là et
fait plein de films et vous l'avez dit
la ville avait un charisme étonnant il
avait ce je me souviens avoir été le
voir dans les loges où il y avait un
silence de cathédrale ou où tout le
monde vous avez à peine le regarder dans
les yeux alors que lui cultive est
exactement le contraire d'ailleurs lui
les quelques fois où j'ai eu la chance
d'aller voir c'était plutôt lui qui me
demandait un peu timide si léo son
concert était bien alors que que je que
je bafouille est quoi c'est m alors si
certains a vraiment un seigneur vous
allez lui rendre j'imagine hommage ce
soir sur scène bah hommage comme comme
je peux le faire très modestement c'est
là que sais je vais être bien bien seule
et bien et bien con avec mes petites
chansons le jour de la disparition
d'alain merci beaucoup en tout cas merci
bénabar pour ce témoignage ce soir ça
c'est en mai réaction est bon concert
tout de même avec votre public
un record maintenant pour un dessin
crayon original de bd celui de la
couverture de l'album d'hergé
le tram aux pinces d'or qui s'est vendu
cet après midi aux enchères à paris
trois cent soixante douze mille euros
direction de ville maintenant où se
tient jusqu'à demain
le 11e festival du cinéma asiatique et
parmi les films en compétition the
chaser un long métrage sud coréens dont
le pays est l'invité d'honneur cette
année
marie-jo joue en évinçant bouffartigue
dénicher un bijou la perle rare le
festival du film asiatique est à l'image
de ce chercheur de trésor un détecteur
de talents de ces pays lointains
image subi déroutante violentes ou
totalement tic 11 ans de rendez vous
avec des cinéastes confirmés
lee chang dong a été ministre de la
culture en corée hong et cinéastes
émergents
nanjing présente son premier film
l'ordonnateur du festival a donné cette
année la priorité au cinéma coréen
incontournable ce festival est fait
d'abord pour mettre en avant ce que moi
je considère être comme la plus grande
cinématographie du monde la plus
inventive la plus créative elle et
fougueuse et les rageuse ou palpitante
the chaser déjà numéro un au box office
coréen est un thriller haletant
inspiré d'un fait divers qui fit la une
des journaux de séoul
la vingtaine de meurtres avoués par un
tueur en série
entre 2003 et 2004
ces divers relaté dans les journaux
parlent d'une réelle violence contre
avec force détails on les lit et on les
oublie moi ce que je voulais c'est
montrer ses scènes aux spectateurs dans
les ports quel est leur rôle dans un
film violent et humains à travers la
rédemption d'un ancien flic devenu
proxénète livrant une course poursuite
pour sauver une de ces prostituées maman
d'une petite fille
donc le jury de stars françaises va
avoir du mal à départager ces oeuvres
atypiques
on peut avoir des a priori sur ce qu'on
connaît moins bien et la scène qu'à
vraiment pour ma part je suis pas du
tout expertes
donc je me laisse toujours surprendre se
laisser surprendre comme les milliers de
spectateurs cinéphiles qui découvrent
chaque année à deauville de nouveaux
trésors sûr que le voyage sera des
paysans
il a fait beau aujourd'hui dans le sud
de la france et promet rayon de soleil
donnait un air de printemps alors en
terrasse ou sur la plage
rencontre avec quelques privilégiés à
juan les pins reportage n'at-elle
jourdan et nice bruni c'est pas un peu
tôt pour le maillot 16 degrés au soleil
pas assez poursuit mais suffisant pour
creuser tu creuses pour quoi faire
14 mars 2009 jean les pins premiers
rayons de soleil et première attaque de
vagues repousser le château et sauver la
plage ratissée y'a plus qu'à aller se
baigner
c'est bon c'est la fin de l'hiver l'un
quoi on peut dire que c'est l'été qui
est en avance après un hiver horrible
qu'on a eue avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
plus en novembre
là on récupère un petit peu dans l'eau
au clou en paix ça ne se bouscule pas
vraiment elle est à 13 degrés ça fait du
bien à tous les jours ça sonne mieux un
petit qu au sexe est pas mal non plus
paroles de parisiens est le premier
rempart au soleil comme en extérieur
pour profiter d'un beau soleil comme
aujourd'hui et surtout une température
meilleure température et formes
généreuses
attention elle a une semaine pour
maigrir il faut faire de la place pour
les premiers touristes
samedi prochain c'est le printemps voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à vous
de m'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
nathalie rihouet 20h35 théâtre en direct
avec la maison du lac maria pacôme et
jean piat depuis le théâtre de paris je
vous retrouve demain pour toute
l'actualité dès 13h et puis pour 13h15
le dimanche avec daniel cohn bendit et
vincent lindon passé une très belle
soirée et on se quitte en musique avec
un bashung
le coût de la vie
au sol et dézéry soyez manu
et
tous
etc